(crickets chirping)
- [Voiceover] Every place
in the world sounds unique.
These soundscapes tell us
a story about that place.
They tell us the ways
in which global warming
is beginning to change
the natural soundscape.
Just before the sun rises at first light
is the dawn course.
(nature sounds)
The birds begin to sing and the insects
and the amphibians.
And that's the time of day
to go out and listen.
I'm a soundscape ecologist
and I record animals for a living.
This is Sugarloaf State Park.
Every spring, I can
probably be found there
once a week recording in the same spot
using the same kind of
equipment so that I could
repeat these recordings
over and over again
and compare them.
And I have quite an archive of material
which shows, over time,
this habitat has been
changing pretty radically as
a result of global warming
and the California drought.
(birds chirping)
The first recording made
in 2004 shows a very robust
habitat with a signature of a stream.
(nature sounds)
In 2014, things were changing radically.
It was already the second
year of a major drought
in California.
And then 2015, we had what
I call a silent spring.
Over 50 percent of my
collection comes from habitats
that are so radically
altered they're either
altogether silent or
can no longer be heard
in their original form.
Here's an example from Costa Rica.
(nature sounds)
That's before logging, this is after.
(soft hum)
Same spot.
This is a coral reef, Vanua Levu in Fiji.
Part of it is dying and
part of it is still living.
Here's what the living part sounds like.
(water sounds)
And here's what the dying part sounds like.
Hardly any fish sounds.
(calm instrumental)
We really don't know what
this means in the long run.
In the short run, we're beginning
to lose these soundscapes
because the habitats are just changing so radically
and we're partly to blame for that.
When I first began to
record, almost 50 years ago,
I would go out into the
field and just put on a pair
of earphones and sit and listen
because it made me feel good.
It made me aware of the
living world around me,
and so I want to do anything
that does that for me.
(nature sounds)
(calm instrumental)